what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and Thor love and
thunder is now in theaters and there's a
lot to talk about including the ending
and the two post credit scenes so let's
not waste any time and dive right into
it but of course I must issue a spoiler
warning if you have not seen Thor love
and thunder yet we are about to talk
about some Major Spoilers and please
right away let me know what you thought
about 411 Thunder in the comments down
below did you like it did you not like
it did you love it did you hate it let
me know if you're still with us let's
get started now one thing that I truly
loved about Thor love and thunder is how
the stories in it were pretty true to
the comics now of course there were some
changes but this really did stick true
to the stories from the comics
specifically Jane Foster's storyline
again with just a few tweaks and if
you're thinking that she is dead and not
coming back I would bet against that and
say that she is probably coming back and
I'll explain why now of course Thor love
and thunder follows the story of Thor
odinson Jane Foster is the mighty Thor
and Gore the god butcher Gore the god
butcher's origin story is pretty similar
to what it is in the comics in the
comics Gore has a big family he has a
wife and he has a lot of kids but sadly
they all start to die until he's left
with only one child he begs the gods for
Mercy to help save his kid but
unfortunately it does nothing and his
son dies leaving Gore with no family
whatsoever so after this happens he
starts to kind of bad talk the gods and
he starts to say how he doesn't believe
that they're out there because if they
were why didn't they help this leads to
the people of his City outcasting him
and he is essentially walking through
the wastelands waiting to die until he
sees two figures fall from the sky to
the ground one is a golden god wearing
gold armor and one is null the Symbiote
God wielding the all-black necro sword
and we kind of do see a figure that kind
of looks like null in Thor 11 Thunder
although they don't actually address who
he is and the rights to null and the
Symbiotes are sadly owned by Sony so we
can't really say this is null but that's
what they're implying now in the comics
it's a little bit different because the
golden god asked score for help but Gore
is shocked because he can't believe that
the gods are actually real but then he
gets really really mad because he knows
the gods are real but did not help him
so instead of helping the God he takes
the all-black necro sword and he kills
him this is pretty much what we saw in
the beginning of Thor love and thunder
Gore afterwards takes the all-black
necro sword and makes a vow to kill all
the gods becoming Gore the god butcher
he would try to kill Thor on Earth but
the Vikings come to Thor's rescue and
this causes Gore to retreat and
eventually Thor goes on to hunt him down
meanwhile the story of Jane Foster in
the comics is very very similar to what
we saw on screen Jane Foster is
diagnosed with cancer and Thor actually
becomes unworthy to lift mjolnir this is
caused by Nick Fury actually Whispering
something into Thor's ear on the moon
which wasn't revealed at the time but
would later go on to be revealed that
Nick Fury said Gore was right meaning
that the world would be better if there
were no gods in it but the hammer then
makes its way to Jane Foster with the
help of Heimdall where she is able to
wheel mjolnir becoming the Mighty Thor
now in the movie I actually really
really enjoy how Jane Foster became
worthy to lift mjolnir when showing us
the backstory of Thor and Jane dating we
see that Thor one night while Jane was
asleep and he was admiring her is
talking to mjolnir and he asked mjolnir
to protect her at all costs and always
be there for her this is one reason that
mjolnir calls out to Jane while she has
cancer they also reveal that Jane is
worthy to lift mjolnir because when Thor
was actually unworthy in the very first
Thor film Jane is the one who believed
in Thor and helped him become worthy so
Jane Foster who was dying of cancer
transforms into the Mighty Thor when she
is wielding the hammer when she
transforms into the Mighty Thor she has
all the strength of a Thor of a god
unfortunately much like in the comics
this actually kills her when she's
transformed into a god two things
actually happen one is that her body
actually cleanses itself of all poison
therefore it removes itself of all of
the chemotherapy that has been done to
it because chemo is poison that attacks
cells so the body sees this this as an
attack and when she becomes a god it
gets rid of the chemo making the chemo
completely unaffective also at the same
time her cells Harden because they
become like a god cells which in turn
makes the cancer cells even stronger so
lifting and wielding mjolnir literally
kills her much like we saw in the movie
she dies in the comics and she goes to
Valhalla but eventually Thor would end
up bringing her back now she would
arrive in the same condition back on
Earth still having cancer but she ends
up beating it and ends up becoming a
valkyrie so I'm assuming something very
similar is going to be happening in the
MCU Jane is going to come back and help
Thor raise love now there's actually
time travel involved in the comic story
of Gore the god Butcher and there are
many different thores involved as well a
past Thor a future Thor The Avengers is
Thor and here's where the story kind of
is a little bit different but
essentially the same Gore is building a
god bomb a bomb that would destroy all
of the Gods in the universe now in the
movie they replaced this with eternity
eternity would Grant a wish to the
person that gets to him and since
eternity is basically the universe
itself it can grant that wish side note
we finally saw a cosmic entity in the
MCU and it was truly awesome so Gore
makes it to Eternity and his plan was to
wish for all of the Gods to be dead and
in the final moment Thor chooses to
spend his last moments what he believes
are his last moments with Jane and he
says he chooses love and that Gore can
too he can bring his daughter back Gore
realizes that he's dying and says that
his daughter will have nobody but Jane
says that she will have somebody and she
looks at Thor and Thor agrees basically
saying that he will take care of his
daughter now all throughout the movie
Jane Foster is trying to come up with a
catchphrase and right before she dies
she tells Thor that she thinks she
finally found one she Whispers in his
ear and Thor says it's perfect and
unfortunately we don't know what it is
this is a node to the comics where Nick
Fury Whispers and Thor's ear and we
originally don't know what he said down
the road Thor would eventually reveal it
to Beta Ray Bill so this is a little
callback to that moment but I think we
all know what Jane Foster said she said
it's Thor Urban time dude I'm like boom
you looking for this
sadly Jane Foster dies Gore dies as well
and Thor ends up with a daughter love
born from eternity who has some pretty
cool powers that I know we're going to
be seeing in the future of the MCU now
this is more of a Redemption Arc for
Gore in the comics he actually manages
to bring his wife and his son back in a
way but eventually he gets really mad
because his wife ends up calling him a
God and Gore kills his wife his son then
releases some thores who were held
captive and tells them to kill his
father so the movie version is a much
nicer Redemption for Gore the god
butcher now like I mentioned the second
post-credits scene we see Jane Foster
arrive in Valhalla she became the Mighty
Thor she became a God and she chose to
fight and save the universe rather than
save her own life this earned her a spot
in Valhalla and she is greeted by none
other than heimdel Heimdall says thank
you for looking after my son you are
very welcome here to the land of the
Gods welcome to Valhalla now like I
mentioned in the comics this happens
Jane dies in battle so she earns a spot
in Valhalla but Thor channels the God
Tempest through the broken mjolnir and
manages to call back Jane's
Consciousness into her body here she's
given another second chance she beats
cancer and like I mentioned comes back
as a valkyrie I'm assuming that
something similar is going to happen
here as in the movie after all the
credits are done it says Thor will
return and considering how well-received
Jane Fosters The Mighty Thor was I'd say
that she's coming back as well now in
the movie we saw Thor and the rest of
the gang go to omnipotent City where
Zeus and a bunch of other gods dwell
unfortunately the other gods were kind
of a disgrace and zero help at all they
end up fighting the gods and Zeus throws
a thunderbolt through Korg this puts
Thor in a rage as he thinks that Korg is
dead so he takes Zeus's Thunderbolt as
it's thrown at him throws it right back
at Zeus and seemingly kills him however
in the first post-credit scene it is
revealed that Zeus is alive and he's
pretty mad he says it used to be that
being a god meant something people would
whisper your name before sharing their
deepest hopes and dreams They begged you
for Mercy without knowing if you were
actually listening Zeus then laughs and
says now when they look to the sky they
don't ask us for lightning they don't
ask us for rain they just want to see
one of their so-called superheroes this
is obviously a reference to Thor as he
is the God of Thunder but also on Earth
is an Avenger and a superhero this is
demonstrated actually in Thor Ragnarok
when he's sitting with Loki on the side
of the street and people come up to him
and ask to take his picture but Zeus
continues and he says when did we become
the joke he says no more they will fear
us again when Thor odinson falls from
the sky then it's revealed that he's
actually talking to somebody he says do
you understand me Hercules do you
understand me my son Hercules is
revealed and he says yes father now for
those of you who watched Ted lasso you
instantly know who this is it is the
actor Brett Goldstein who plays Roy Kent
and Ted lasso and he has packed on some
serious muscle to play the role of
Hercules which of course you have to
it's Hercules now in the comics Thor and
Hercules actually run into each other
quite often and yes in the very
beginning they did Clash a little bit
and fight but for the most part they are
actually allies in fact at one point in
time Hercules is even an Avenger and
they even refer to each other at some
points as closest allies so although
when Hercules and Thor are going to
first meet in the MCU I do see them
clashing I ultimately think that
Hercules is going to be a good guy in
fact in the comics Hercules even
realizes that his father Zeus isn't
exactly the best and Hercules turns on
him and with the help of Thor Zeus is
eventually put on trial so I'm assuming
something very similar is going to
happen here in the MCU Thor and Hercules
will fight but Thor will eventually
explain hey I was trying to save the
universe and your father did nothing to
help he was actually scared and actually
kind of stood in Thor's way telling him
that he couldn't leave a nippoten city
this will probably Open the Eyes of
Hercules realizing that Thor was
actually in the right and his father was
in the wrong and that people shouldn't
fear the gods but the god should
actually be helping the people I'm kind
of expecting this to somewhat be like
Guardians of the Galaxy and Adam Warlock
yes The Sovereign created Adam Warlock
to destroy the Guardians of the Galaxy
but I'm betting by the end of the movie
Guardians 3 Adam Warlock becomes a
guardian of the galaxy and is actually a
hero much like in the comics and those
are the post-credit scenes and the
ending for Thor love and thunder let me
know what you thought of the movie I
want to know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe if you love
Marvel and the MCU for live updates you
can follow me on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
foreign